so thank you Chris that's really great
to be here at Stanford so um so I
started out giving this talk of various
IBM research labs around the world
trying to encourage the artists and
practitioners to work together and then
I said hey I'm going to try universities
- so you're my third I did MIT and
Harvard about three or four months ago
and Stanford's next and so anyway I'm
really excited to be here so just
curious how many people here be yourself
kind of as a theoretician okay how many
people view yourself as kind of a
practitioner okay more and how many of
you were database people in some sense
okay good okay great so just going to
assist my audience so the purpose of my
talk is to encourage collaboration
between theoreticians and here I call
them system builders my original version
I call them practitioners and then
someone told me I was insulting them my
unit sounded too well level so I
upgraded the word the assistant builder
don't one insult anybody and I'm gonna
do this with two case studies and a
little some case studies something
succeed with some dump at a spoiler
alert is they both succeeded the ones
you're gonna hear about and they were
initiated in two different ways one way
was the practitioner coming to me
can we these are stories about stuff
I've done because that's what I know the
best
so practitioner coming to me and the
second case study is the theoreticians
deciding on their own we're going to do
this theory and and we're going to
encourage the practitioners to use it so
yeah and one thing I want to convince
irritations of is the following that
working with practitioners is not a
penalty you pay it's not like oh I've
got to do it I'm a theoretician to get
tenure or to get have people at IBM be
happy I've got to do it instead I'm
gonna argue it's a positive good that
you will actually do better theory if
you interact with practitioners you'll
find new interesting problems no one has
done before and you'll set a trend and
you'll
it's good and I'll giving samples to the
talk of that so my basic argument is
going to be it's a positive good for
theoreticians to work with practitioners
they'll do better theory and for the
practitioners or system builders point
of view they will build better stuff
better products from my beans point of
view if they just dare to talk to to
theoreticians so that's what I just said
so forth ear tissues the idea I'm going
to talk about how to apply theory to
practice by example and as I said it'll
lead the better theory and for
practitioners to help understand the
value of theory how I could possibly
help them and the value of involving
theoreticians so let's talk about these
two sets of people the the system
builders in the practice and the
theoreticians of the system builders
what do they like well they're strong
software architects and programmers they
understand their system thinking they
have a large vocabulary for software
issues software and design patterns
architecture api's lots of stuff so they
have their own vocabulary the
theoreticians dot typically is they work
in teams to produce complex systems you
could argue that these systems are so
complicated that no one person could
really understand it you really do need
a team to do it
they're exceptions I guess like Knuth
doing tech I mean he really understood
everything but generally that's not true
and and they have very good insights
into their problem domains so when the
theoretician works with this
practitioner this is these people really
know they're what's important and what's
not important they know what needs to be
done patients on the other hand are
strong have strong precise mathematical
thinking they can generalize well and
find helpful abstractions some other
examples of that in the talk they can
find good formal structures that they
can use to help model whatever the
practitioner is doing and help drive
results about it they know many
algorithms they could come up with more
most see examples of that
and can prove properties of systems and
algorithms so the first case study went
way back to 1996 and has gone on since
so so this was some work with with Laura
has now for those of you who don't know
where has she
she's an IBM fellow at at home and Dan
she was a director of our computer
science department now she's the
director of our advanced re discovery
lab which I just recently joined so but
she's a long history to IBM and she came
to see me way that fit she was just the
first level manager working on a project
called garlic so she came up to me one
day and knocked on my door and said okay
mr. data makes the addition we got a
problem with garlic I said okay what's
the problem well the problem was this
the garlic is a system on top of other
systems well it's it's middleware so
it's on top of a standard database
engine like IBM's db2 it's on top of
cubic which is Korea by image content
where you can look at images and you can
query them on the basis of their color
or their shape or their texture and on
top of various other systems as well so
that's that's what but garlic was and
the problem was the following that the
answers to two queries in db2 or any
traditional database system is a set or
sometimes it's a bag but for Laura's
case it's a set where in as answers to
queries in cubic or sorted lists you
know give me the reddest object second
register greatest and so on so you've
sorted lists so problem is how do you
combine these together how do you make
sense of if you want to do an and or
something so in the one hand you have
sets the other hand you have sorted
lists how do you put these together
they've seen to be mismatched she was
really concerned because how can you be
on top of them both and you don't know
what to do with them but how to combine
them so let's consider example let's say
we have a CD database and we're
searching for artists equals Beatles and
now that'll give us a set via say db2
now these are from musicbrainz that's a
music library at public music library
that has metadata about music it has
information about 12 million CDs in it
so here is
the set you get back if you say artist
Eagles beetles now let's say you said
album color equals red and you're using
cubic to do it what happens then
well here's what you get back and this
was actually done for me by Richard
Gabriel who's a who used to be at
Stanford I worked at Stanford he is an
expert on photographic manipulation and
he came up with an algorithm for redness
that actually I showed was the unique
one with certain properties and that
come up again the student notion of
something be the unique thing with
certain properties but anyway by his
algorithm the reddest thing was the
first guy there had a score point six
nine seven by his redness algorithm now
I personally think the fourth what's the
reddest but apparently there's too much
dark pixels in there so it didn't win so
it's got a lower score but anyway by his
Agra that these are the four reddest so
some but it's a sorted list now so how
do we make sense of combining them well
if I gave you the query artist equals
Beatles and album color equals red
you'll say oh I have no big deal we'll
we'll just sort it give all the albums
by the Beatles sorted by how ready our
big deal what's the problem
okay how about artist equals Beatles or
album color equals red now what are you
gonna do it's not clear at all what you
would do then and how about if you have
a peer multimedia query forget these CDs
let's just say color is red and shape is
round and in cubic how do you do that
you have a redness list you're around
this list how do you aggregate these
somehow and find the the top K answers
say what do you do so what was my
solution well what I told world was
first I realized this they this often
happens when a practitioner comes to you
with a problem they they leave out
something important and what she left
out this important was that these
weren't just sorted list they were
scored list you remember that picture
with the colors there was us color score
for each one of these not just a top one
second third but they all had scores so
I thought AHA and I knew that because I
actually done some work on keeping I
wrote a paper about shape matching in
cubic so I knew about cubic so I knew
that they were really scored list
but sets are also scored with
everybody's a score zero or one so
suddenly we run common ground suddenly
we're dealing with scored lists for both
in both cases so now we've scored list
we're gonna combine them well that's
that's pretty well studied this reminded
me of fuzzy logic where you have a
degree of membership and you want to
somehow combine them and now in fuzzy
logic conjunction is taking to be the
men and disjunctions take to be the max
and there's a famous theorem called the
bellman Gertz theorem which to me is the
most interesting theorem in fuzzy logic
which says that these are the unique
choices with certain desirable
properties now when I gave this talk at
MIT Scott Aaronson raised his hand and
said what's wrong with using
probabilities well what's wrong with
using probabilities was the following
let's say you had color equals red has a
score of P between zero and circle
between zero and one how about color
equals red and color equals red you
might think gosh P squared that doesn't
feel right because how can you have two
equivalent things Congress red versus
color goes right n coma R equals red
with two different scores bad so that's
what goes wrong with probabilities
there's no notion of Independence and
but you know it's min does just the
right thing in that case it gives
Congress red in color turns red if
scores P on Congress red then the
conjunction is also P so it does the
right thing it'll always do the right
thing in these getting their precise
says so sum up great so I went back to
war and said Laura I got you an answer
use fuzzy logic and so she said good I
mean I'm happy with that that's believed
that there was some kind of solution but
but now I'm worried because of
efficiency she said you know we can't
afford to look at every single object in
the database this could be a huge
database and and try to get the scores
and everything and combine them together
we just can't do that we need an
efficient algorithm so meaning okay so I
went went back to my room and thought
about it and came back a day or two
later so hey Laura
I've got you a square root of n
algorithm it's not n which is n is the
number of objects in the databases like
the number of CDs so
it's not in which is what the naive
algorithm does its square root of n
which is a lot better so so so that's
effect pretty efficient
so I'll never forget what she said to me
then she said that's good square root of
n certainly beats
linear she said but we dated makes
people were spoiled we're used to log in
we're used to to you know be trees and
all she said be smarter go back to your
office
give me a login algorithm you don't
forget these things so I remember her
saying that so he went back to my office
and came back in the air too later I
said ok where I can prove to you you
can't do better than square root of n
that's it she said fine okay I surrender
we'll take it we'll implement that in
garlic so so that's what happened now
let's just look at the time for the
accesses to give you an idea Y square
root of n is really better than n in
practice so let's say we have music
brains with 12 million CDs so n is 12
million and let's say you have a
thousand accesses per second so if you
do the naive algorithm that looks at
every single thing in the database
that's going to take you about three
hours
square root of n takes about three
seconds so really does make a difference
square root of n versus and really does
make a difference in practice so it
really does turn something inefficient
or something efficient and and then it's
something theoreticians do is to
generalize the algorithm I realized I
didn't use it just use min I can in
physiologic I can use other scoring
functions I could use the average or the
median and in fact they're psychological
studies showing that people when they
you do you combine scores they tend to
like some flavor of average and you say
this is the winner based on men they say
I don't like that winner but this is the
winner based on some flavor of average
like geometric mean or our arithmetic
mean they say that looks pretty good you
know that's a pretty good choice for the
number one guy so I wanted to generalize
it beyond and and the algorithm that I
gave Laura the square root of an
algorithm does generalize now it works
for any monotone scoring function I'll
define that firmly in a second but the
intuition is simply that if you if you
increase the scores you cannot decrease
the value the result which is very
intuitive you certainly don't want some
way of combining scores where
if you drop some of the score if you a
few if you raise some of the scores then
the overall value would drop that would
be pretty bad so this is not a real
restriction to use monotone scoring
functions
okay so influence well this algorithm
was implemented garlic as I told you and
went on to be implemented in everybody
in products these things I have listed
here in this list I won't read them to
you but they're based in part on garlic
and the paper rain or just my algorithm
by the which is called Fagin saagara
then people refer to in papers as that
has over 800 citations now according to
Google Scholar so so it had an impact a
lot of people jumped on board and said
this is interesting and this is an
important question they consider the
number of database accesses we want to
do that too so lots of people did that
I'm a thin a few years later money an
hour and I'm not a low demand I work
together we found a new algorithm and
then you are greater than we call the
threshold algorithm and I'm going to
scribe you in a moment how it works and
it's optimal in a very strong sense it's
optimal not just the worst case or the
average case but in every case so
typically when when theoreticians talk
about the goodness vinegar and they
consider worst case so if for a given
size of n of the number of items they'll
look at what happens in the worst case
you get no credit for how well you do it
on almost all the other cases if you do
well under them so but this is really
powerful to do it's up to a constant
factor as well as any algorithm in in
every case because consider the
following you're the adversary can come
up with his own database and he can find
an algorithm I'm making a he by the way
said if she cuz it's gonna be a little
bit evil you know so I don't want to be
sexist or anything so so the the
adversary
comes up with his own database and his
own algorithm fine tune to that database
and to be in sis optimal you've got to
do as well as the adversary's algorithm
on the adversary's database that's a
tough thing to do I mean consider
something like binary search in binary
search which is a login thing
here's an algorithm that shows that
that's not the best so let's say you're
searching you see if a thousand is in
your data so the adversary designs his
little database where it's at position
123 and his algorithm for four searches
goes as follows
step one look in position 123 if it's
not there do binary search it's a good
algorithm it's perfectly legitimate and
it'll kill binary search on this pace
because it'll find if you're searching
for 123 it'll find it in one step
poor old binary search takes long again
sniffs oh so binary search is not incest
optimal it's tough to be instance
optimal by the way honey story button
assess optimality is that after we came
up with this notion David Johnson came
to visit me you know Gary and Johnson
and I told you about this very probably
talking about instance optimality and he
said you know Ron I feel like if you
weren't caught incest optimal you got to
not only fulfill your conditions of your
definition but you got to have the best
possible constant that have a man so so
actually I was able to prove it it's the
best possible constant it was kind of
hairy because the constants kind of
hairy but it was and so I use called
that David Johnson optimal it's really
optimal a strong sense so now let me
tell you what the problem it must be
more concrete about this because we're
talking about the problem yes it just so
happens you want to do as well as you
can
heck to know when people say this is an
optimal algorithm they it you know
you're not irritation but you want your
database on your database if I can tell
you Hector that on your database my
algorithm will do as well as any other
than you could possibly dream of on your
database then you know you should be
happy I can say look Hector I am solving
your problem
I know without knowing what's in your
database you whatever your debut says I
can do my algorithm is so good that
it'll beat any algorithm you can come up
with even one that's fine tuned to that
database I mean you should be happy with
it
this is this is a better than the
average case no no oh yeah definitely
because the average case you may not be
the average case in fact if it ever
takes is a little murky because you know
it's not clear what the probably
distribution is a year you are so on
your database whatever it may be you're
getting the best you can the answer as
quickly as possible that does that make
you happy Hector no I claim that that's
I mean it's only the best thing you
could possibly hope for well you put it
that way it's better than an average
case it's better than this case so it's
as good as you could hope for that
situation but it's good might appreciate
questions so thank you actor so so going
back to what is a problem let's be
really concrete about it so there are M
attributes and the case I'm going to
give you by examples and this - we're
gonna have redness and around this so M
is - two attributes we'll keep that in
mind that special case you have and each
object has a redness cord around the
score it's got a score for every
attribute how red it is how round it is
and the objects are given an M sorted
list so you have the redness list here's
the reddest second registered redness
and so on here's around this list around
the second round us and so on I mean
this really does model it goes on inside
a cubic and and your goal was to find
the top K according to some monotone
scoring function so then that means is
if it's got a redness score of 0.6 and
around the score 0.8 and your your
function is the average then the overall
score is 0.7 and if it's many at any
point six and you want to get the top K
so that's the problem you want to
finally the top ten that's that's what
we're trying to do and now I mentioned
voting in the abstract so you can think
of these attributes as voters if there's
a redness voter and around this voter
and you can think of the objects those
candidates so from the redness voters
point of view his favorite choice is the
reddest guy's the second choice the
second reticence
Anees assigning the me scores from the
roundness pointer voters point of view
his favorite is the roundest guy with
yeah and he gives us high score to the
round this guy's second highest score to
the second round this guy and so on so
you can think of these as voters it's a
nice way to think of it so so let's look
at it multimedia example here's redness
and around this so here's our database
and so the reddest guy is this object
177 it's really really red score 0.99 3
see in the upper left hand corner down
in the lower right corner you see it's
not so round as 0.406 kind of mediocre
lis around and you'll see the round this
guy the upper right hand corner
really really really round probably a
circle point 9 9 9 and you'll see in the
bottom left is his redness scores not so
great point 3 2 5 very nuts not so red
ok so now we are going back to scoring
function so let F be the scoring
function and popular choices are men
which I mentioned using fuzzy logic and
average and there's various other
flavors of average these are popular
choices for scoring functions people use
in practice now if you had three voters
and one is 1.7 million point three seven
there gives a score point five then if
our scoring function is the average then
you know it gets dragged down a little
bit by the point five guy but gets does
very well by the point seven guys so
it's a legitimate way to do it didn't
you take the average people do that a
lot so let's let x1 through XM be the
scores of some object under the M
attributes so the first we're here we're
doing endless to it so there's a redness
cordon around the score for M equals to
that F of these scores is the overall
score
so just like I was saying if scores four
point seven point seven point five and
you're doing the minute the average
would be the average at point seven
point seven point five so we may write F
of R for f of X 1 through X M so there's
a your this concrete scoring function
and now our definition monotones
probably what you think it is that if X
sub I of s are equal to Y I for every I
then F of the exercise is less than or
equal to f of the Y I so that's what it
means to be monotone so if if one guy's
got at least as good score is just
another guy in every attribute that his
overall scores at least is good so
that's my ethnicity and now it turns out
that there's two modes of access in
cubic and other systems one is sorted or
sequential access what you do is you say
give me the reddest guy now give me the
second rate of sky now I'm gonna give me
the third greatest guy and their scores
so give me the rate of Skynet score and
so on and then there's also random
access you say okay I just saw this
object number 235 I saw its round the
score what's its redness score so you
can go look it up and say it's point
three four three or whatever so you can
do random access and sorted access and
I'm not going to Singlish them in this
talk although in the paper we do
distinguish them sometimes considering
when one is more out than the other and
but the basic results are about the same
so we're not going to do that today just
count accesses and we wish to minimize
the total number of accesses is our goal
now for algorithms we want an algorithm
that finds the top K objects and now the
naive algorithm just looks at every
single object in the database gets its
score and it's readiness scores around a
score gets a score and all the
attributes calculates F of those scores
for every object sorts them and says
okay here's the winner it's got the
highest overall score your second place
third place so that's a naive algorithm
in fact the funny thing is people used
to think these scoring relations were
trivial like rank aggregation where you
don't have scores is hard it's np-hard I
want to go into the details but scoring
aggregation people always thought of
this trivial I mean you just calculate
the scores and sort of the bit here
suddenly it's an important issue about
how much data you have to look at that's
what Laura Haas was concerned
so it's not so trivial anymore so as I
said the naive algorithms to expensive
so let me tell you our Agra the
threshold algorithm and here's how it
works so you you do parallel access you
do sort of access in parallel to the two
lists so here's the redness listen
around this list you find the rate of
subject second rightousness and so on
same with this you're moving your
fingers down the list and then as soon
as you see an object under sorted access
you go get it score and the other lists
in random access so now if you just saw
object 235 and around this list you go
get a score the read this list and you
find F of those values and and that's
this overall score and you and then you
keep track of the of the top case scores
so if this one of the top cancers you
see so far you keep it and you remember
what object it was you remember what
score otherwise throw it away it's never
going to be it can't possibly be in the
top KK that's already been beaten by by
K guys so now here's what we do now we
need a stopping rule when did we stop
doing this well for each list that I let
TI be the score and the last object you
saw under sorted access so so as you're
moving your finger down where was your
finger and sorted access in this list
and where's your finger and that we has
to find F of those two scores the last
scores you saw it or started access no
that's not the score of any particular
object necessarily but still
mathematically it makes sense to
calculating is certainly fine if you're
doing average the average of those two
numbers so let's call that the threshold
and then here's your stopping rule as
soon as you've seen K objects at least K
objects whose score is at least equal to
the threshold stop and output the top K
answer so that's the algorithm you you
go down you calculate this threshold
value and as soon as you see K objects
whose scores at least that threshold and
stop and output your current table K so
why is this correct algorithm first of
all well let's see first of all this
this let's see how this works a little
bit in practice so here's the let's say
we're using men which easy to use so
the first option you saw in the reddest
list was 177 with that score 0.99 3 the
first object you saw in the roundness
list was 235 or the score 0.999 and then
you go get the score of the greatest
object in the roundness list and the
score of the roundest object the redness
score the roundest object and just as we
discussed before and so the overall
score now we know for object 177 it's
the min of putting 99 3 and point 406
which is 0.40 6 and so on for the other
and now what is your threshold well you
this as far as you've gone so far with
your fingers is just the top one so far
so you find the min of those two numbers
so the minute put 99 three and point
nine nine nine which is point nine nine
three and you don't stop yet because
you're really pretty far from having K
objects of scores at least that you keep
on going you go to the next objects in
the list and now you calculate the
threshold your secret steadily drop as
you move down so now the with your
fingers in the second position of both
lists you have a the scores are point
nine nine one and point nine nine five
and so you take the min of those and
that's point nine nine five is so now
the thresholds a little bit lower you
keep going and threshold keeps dropping
now it's the minute point nine eight two
and point nine nine two and you keep on
going doing this process and getting
scores of the objects until you find at
least K objects whose score is at least
equal that threshold so now let's see
why this rule is correct why does it
really give you a top K well here's why
so we're at a point now we just stopped
because we have at least K objects whose
scores are at least equal to the
threshold so why are we good well if not
what could go wrong but he'd go wrong is
these are some object are you haven't
seen yet and you're moving down the list
some object s that's in your current top
K and the score of R is better than the
score of s so you made a mistake you
have your top K but there's somebody who
you haven't even seen yet whose score is
better than some in your top Kahless so
you screwed up this is what could go
wrong
well sure that can't happen well let's
say or r has scores X 1 through X a I'm
like it's redness corners around the
score
now this implies that X is less than or
equal that ti that threshold value for
that list because you haven't seen it
yet you've your finger has not gotten
down to that object yet so X is less
than or equal to CI because R has not
been seen yet
well then F of R F of this object f of T
1 through TM by monotonicity or f of X 1
through xn is by monotonicity is less
than or equal to f of the t1 through TM
and that's what monotonicity tells you
that that if x is 0 TI then after the
exercise lesson with f of the t is well
that's that's the threshold value T and
we've assumed our object ass has score
at least equal to the threshold so f of
s is greater than T so there's our
contradiction contradiction is above we
had f of r is bigger than f of s and
down here we have f of our less than
equal to f of s that's a contradiction
so this bad thing i told you that cannot
happen so it really was a correct rule
it really when it stopped it really had
correctly given top K values so you know
the importance of the hotting rules
first of all you certainly want younger
than to be correct
you want to guaranteed to give the top K
and we just showed that a second thing
is you want speed in fact our algorithm
know correct halting rule can stop any
sooner that's something we prove and and
intuitively look at what could happen is
that the very next object you see in the
list could have score equal to that
threshold value so you better better
know how to stop before then if you stop
before then you you miss somebody
because you've not don't have K guys
who's who scores at least equal to the
threshold so anyway that's so it's as
good as you can get so so I I was very
happy went to see Laura and I said Laura
we have a new algorithm now the
threshold algorithm it's even better
than that Vegas algorithm that shows you
before and she said what she said Ron
you told me your algorithm is optimal
we've already implemented it and now
you're telling me you can do better so I
said well or there's optimal and then
there's optimal
you know it was optimal in a certain
sense this is optimal in a stronger
stance so what can you do that's that's
the way life is so the influence of this
was actually did not reimplemented I'm
too bad yeah that's the way things are
but I'll tell you the funny story about
submitting this paper so we submitted
this paper that Paz 2001 not pods for
those of you don't know is the top
database theory conference and I was
really worried because I thought you
know this algorithms a simple all girl
you saw the algorithm it's really pretty
simple and I was afraid that the program
committee members would look at this
paper and say this is their key
algorithm look how simple it is are they
kidding me I mean this is the top
database 3 Congress reject well so so
they might reject you for that reason to
so but in particular is such a simple
algorithm so I said AHA so what I did in
the both the abstract and in the body of
the paper I call it a remarkably simple
algorithm so I turned a bug into a
feature I said this is remarkably simple
and it worked I mean the paper is
accepted and went on to win the best
paper award so it really didn't this is
something you think advertising is
important so how you phrase your result
is important sometimes it's important to
service all itself so the selling of the
results say many of you know about that
so so I sold it and then it went paper
was quite influential it's now has about
1,600 citations in Google Scholar and to
in 2011 when the test of time award
looking back which paper had the most
influence and then there's the actor
blow technical achievement award which I
won specifically for my work on scoring
or Gatien the those two paper the
Fagin's algorithm and this one here
those two algorithm really was the
reason I won that award and then the
biggie was we won the girl prize last
year the 2014 Corolla prize for the top
paper in theoretical computer science so
that was so it really did have an
influence on the world and and it has
many many applications I mean one reason
it won the
prices this is a partial list you don't
have to read it just glance through it
you'll see that there's many many
different areas or people jumped on the
bandwagon said yeah we can use that dog
or then that's just what we need
I mean people will come to IBM and give
a talk and I won't even know it then
halfway through the talk they said we
use the threshold algorithm and you know
this like it's a given like oh good okay
so it's very widely used morals I'd like
to draw morals for these things so how
did theory help well first of all most
importantly in some ways I resolve
Laura's dilemma
she really was stuck she really had this
problem I've got two databases the one
gift sets one gives sort of lists how do
I combine this I resolved her dilemma so
she was very happy about that knowledge
of the literature I knew about fuzzy
logic and so so I realized okay that I
that's something I could use and I
generalized it later but I realized
fuzzy logic was an answer abstraction I
realized that you can use any scoring
function this monotone you don't need to
use just men like is used in fuzzy logic
another thing theoreticians do that I
did in this case devise optimal
algorithms and prove there and prove
their optimality and another important
thing is to figure out the real problem
as I mentioned Laura did not even think
about the fact their scores so as I said
there's a common thing so to find out
people when people present something to
you they usually tell you a bunch of
things that are irrelevant and leave out
certain relevant thinks so she left out
something relevant so figuring out the
real problem is an important thing to do
another thing is you don't stop at the
original problem for example if shock
Chandra said to me what if you want to
wait the importance of things you have a
these things he called sliders so you
decide that redness is twice as
important as roundness and it's not
obvious what to do in a case like that
like how would you do the min function
where the first arguments twice as
important the second argument far from
clear so we came up with a way to do it
which was the unique one with certain
desirable properties in became desirable
properties of how the weighting should
work and showed we gave a way of doing
it and
so this led to a successful and official
body of work now there's a quote here by
Shafi goldwasser and and this is in her
Turing award interviewing C ACM and she
said if you come up with something new
and it's yours stick with it so I think
that's a good thing you know
we found not after we got this we
continued on found other related
problems and that's what we did and so
measures to success well for IBM errs
it's making our products better which is
an ultimate measure of success for
practitioners and and creating a new sub
feel is something theoreticians care
about and this really did create a new
sub feel that really was something new
where this that's in some ways an
ultimate measure of success for
theoreticians and one of the points I
want to make is here's an example for
those who don't believe that working
with practitioners can give you a better
theory this paper started out as a real
life problem by a real-life practitioner
and it won the gorillas prize which is a
theoretical computer science award so
this is a case study of it really does
pay off and so now in my second case
study which I'm about to show there's
even a better example of it creating a
new subfield so the second case was CLIA
which started in 2003 and what CLIA does
is the following it deals with data
exchange where we data exchange we
convert data from one format to another
maybe XML to relational or maybe one
relational kind of set of tables and
other relational set of tables but you
convert data somehow so Laura started
Cleo right after she garlic so I
followed her I thought well this is a
winner
who knows maybe this'll lead to
something good too I tend to equate
meetings for a year and then some of us
for key and Colitis Renee Miller which
and pop and I said okay let's do even
though no one's asking for it let's see
how would we do the state exchange stuff
for first principles not ad-hoc
principles how you know they're giving
certain ways of giving their answers how
would we do it
so so that's what we did by the way that
picture Renee Miller is aged 3 and she's
not really that young now and she's one
of those people who does not like your
picture and appear and the web so she
agreed I could have her 3 year old
picture so that's that's why there's
this very young Renee Miller and it's a
picture number two so let's say more
about data exchange well you're
translating data from one format to
another so you have a source schema and
a target schema I'll give an example in
just a second and your convert data from
one format to another by some set of
rules
now data exchange is a really old
problem Phil Bernstein causeth the
oldest database problem I want going to
be more but there's there was a a
project in my IBM lab back in 1977 that
transformed data actually those were
hierarchical databases transferring
there's lots of other applications of
data exchange like extract transform
load I'm not going go into the Hat but
I'm going to give an example and
actually we're going to turn this we're
gonna have some fun we're going to turn
this into a quiz so so I'm going to give
you I'm going to give you an example of
conversion and we're going to vote which
is the best way to do it so here it here
we go
so first of all let me tell you the
rules so let's say we have a database
with employees and managers and we want
to convert into some database with
employee department and department
manager so we're suddenly added in this
department and now you need some kind of
a relationship because it's called a
schema mapping and they use these things
called tupple generating dependencies or
TG DS they were originally used for
normal forms don't worry about its
history but here's an example of it so
in this case what we want to say is that
if employee and manager M are in the
employee manager database that's here
then there's some department D where
employee he is in department d
department d is managed by M so that's
that's going to be the rule we're going
to use that's the couple tutoring
dependency that tells us how to do the
conversion so now let's look at a
concrete example here's where we're
gonna have our our fundament voting by
the way when I gave this talk I gave
this talk at MIT and
effort already and they did very well in
the votes so no pressure but you know
I'm gonna see how well Stanford does I
have you know I hope the West Coast can
you know hold its own up here and
Stanford so we'll see okay so here's the
original database
it's got Fagan with his manager or a
Haas she's my management now in the
accelerator discovery lab with I just
joined Ken Carson the manager of our
theory group reports the Laura oz and
our hustler ports to our lab director
Jeff well sir so now I'm going to give
you three candidates that we're gonna
vote on
so here's candidate number one okay
number one is we name the department
after the manager it's something people
often do there for it to you know Bob's
department or something your houses
department so here
Fagen that first Tepes is famous in the
hot department called Haws and the
topped up on the next relation says
Hawes is the manager department Haws and
of course and then Clarkson's and Haas
department managed by Hawes we see and
then housed us in the wells or
department manager very well sir so
that's option number one
okay option number two you say gee I
don't know what the name of the
departments are but whatever it is we'll
call her a husband Department d1 and
it's called a wave although we'll just
call it d1 whatever it is and they're
thanking me Clark center and D 1 and D 1
is managed by Hawes Hajus and Department
D 2 and D 2 is managed by trouser that's
option number 2 on the first one you
really do write in Hollands
ii you really do write in d sub1 there
really is a difference you really are in
one case you really fill in the blank
with and we're in hias here you fill in
the blank with a no label no d sub1 so
you really fill in the blank differently
so that's the difference
so now option 3 option 3 you say well
wait a second just because Fagan and
Clarkson both are part to Hans maybe
they're in different departments maybe
maybe Fagin's and d1 and and Carson City
too and they're both managed by Haws and
Hajus and d3 managed by well sir
these are our three options so what is
the best solution so we're gonna have a
vote so how many like solution number
one I'm explaining the criteria later so
yeah now it's off the table you're sorry
you know it's a little bit big us so
that's the famous you know the
cleverness of the Stanford mind you know
you've got to make your best guess as to
what a good criterion is and later I'm
going to reveal the criterion and see
whether you maybe you'll disagree with
it but so well see that I've got my
strike here and for good reasons so so
let's have a vote I which intuitively
feels the best you not knowing the
criteria which one of these feels the
best okay so how many like solution
number one okay we have a vote over
there
how about solution number two hey what
about sensation number two how about
number three why did more of us on three
okay so so we tell you the answer and
it's the following so we define a notion
of a universal solution at paper a
universal solution is what as general as
possibilities least essentials as
possible and the third solution is
universal that is and when the intuition
behind Universal is that there is a
homomorphism from it into every other
solution that's the form of the
efficient I don't want to go into
homomorphisms here but there's a precise
sense in which this the most general
possible solution and and now if you had
other constraints like let's say you had
the phone that sometimes there is these
constraints on the on the on the output
that says like everything functional
dependencies or equality or any
dependencies that says if Department D
is managed by a manager M and Department
D prime is managed by M that D equals D
prime so that's that's a restriction
often we have things like that on our on
our target and if we had that
restriction then solution two would have
been the best that would have been the
most general possible solution without
its solution number three is the most
general possible solution but in real
life imagine either one could be
possibility to be different do you want
a d2 could be equal for just saying
whatever it is they could be equal they
could be unequal nearest I know anyway
but the point is you are notion
Universal is one that has the least
possible assumptions I mean you can
always start you that that's not a silly
thing to do and that responsible
sumptuous in this case is don't don't
demand that we're a minute has just one
department and by the way by the way can
I are in different departments so they
write and it turns out in real life
the answer was was that but that's not
the only reason just that we want the
most general possible solution which is
the one that makes the least assumptions
we even discuss that offline a little
bit but anyway that's that's our
criterion and and and we we convinced
them of it I mean they bought into it
they change they had very ad hoc ways of
picking a solution we convinced them
that this was the right thing to do how
do we attain these Universal solutions
well there's actually a simple algorithm
for obtaining it there's something
called the chase that I don't want to
firmly defined it I'll give an example
and we use it to generally to general to
generate the target solution from the
source so for example going back to our
example we have here with that
constraint what you do is you take each
type of like you take Fagin and Hazor
the employee manager relation and you
create a new temple here you say Fagin
and D is in the play department relation
and you say that D and Haws are and the
department manager relation for Sundy
and you
pick a nudie for every tupple because
you don't know any better
not to do it and then what you do is if
there are these e gdz these functional
dependencies that tell you when you
equate them like each manager managing
the most of an apartment then you would
equate those two DS otherwise you leave
them alone so that's the civil algorithm
and it actually gets more complicated
when you have more constraints on the
target so I don't want to go into that
now but we still have nice algorithms
now one other thing talking about
continuing on and doing something
different you know if sticking with your
problem like Schoff you said if you got
something good stick with it so we
consider the notion of composition so in
composition let's say you have one way
of going converting data from format 1
to format to another way from converting
from pro matte 2 to format 3 and let's
say you want to go straight from 1 to 3
how do you do that well so I did work on
this with Fukien colitis which and Pope
and went to 10 and studied composition
and it turned out there's some
surprising answers we got that even if
this the mapping from 1 to 2 is very
simple like these TG D's we saw before
and from 2 to 3 is very simple these TG
DS the composition is not only not a TG
necessarily not even for serologic you
have to go to second order logic and and
we had things we call second-order TG DS
so turns out to be surprisingly our
first thought with Bo and I was just
going to not gonna be any big deal
it takes us on a first-order logic and
we found the right way of doing it the
right answer in a precise sense that
these second-order TG DS had the
property that first of all they would
always give you an answer when you
compose things from the first order to
teach it even if you compose them you
get more of them and furthermore for any
second-order tgd there was some sequence
the first order teach it easy to compose
that would give you that answer so it
really was the right formalism he really
showed it a precise sense it was just
the right firm ilysm when you concerned
about composition yeah oh yeah
absolutely everything is finite
yeah there's something you should've
made it and that's not obvious it
doesn't obviously given secondary keys
you can find these always there's always
a fact the fact another paper I wrote
with Alan Ashe and Moranis we prove that
even size two could do it
we spray it when the best paper was icg
t that you can actually get away with to
compose two things and get it so that
was really very surprising and some
people work in the area don't quite
believe it something's gotta be wrong so
so we gave it algorithm for composition
we gave the right language for the
composition measures of assess well this
is used in these various IBM products is
they really bought into a big time they
they used our universal solution so
unlike hector they were convinced that
was the right thing to generate they
thought okay we've been doing in a very
ad hoc way this is this is it this is
what we're going to generate for the
people these universal solutions and
they they used our begin these are auger
than producing universal solution they
used our algorithm for composing schema
mappings and you know for influence the
original paper the one that first
defined universal solutions until how to
do our first paper one the test of time
of word for the ICD t conference in 2013
and then our our composition paper won
that test so timer worked for pods for
last year so these things really did
have an influence people really cared
and it really did influence future work
and it really did create a new subfield
in the sense that after we after we did
our even though it was an old database
problem people weren't writing any
papers on because it wasn't consider
interesting after our original work
suddenly every major database conference
had special sessions on data exchange
converting data so suddenly is a hot
topic and then many many papers were
written since then so so it it really
had an impact in that sense so morals
for this
how did theory help well first of all we
established principles rather than an ad
hoc approach we had
for a principal reason for universal
solutions Hector is its own principal
reasons for not but we had our own
principal reasons for doing that and
they bought into it and this is also we
got algorithms for converting data and
for composing schema mapping so that's
something your tissues do we provide
algorithms
now one thing theorists need a partner
to keep us honest so in our case of his
Lu Chen was one of the people you saw
there that he'd be keep us honest
because he was one of the people who
implemented this and he he would tell us
ok this problem were thinking about now
takes us to never Neverland no one cares
here's the real problems of interest so
it really helps when you're doing this
to have someone who's really grounded in
the project who really knows what the
important issues are so that's really
it's an important moral dead of morals
and never too late to lay the
foundations even for existing systems so
don't forget this cui I'd been going on
for a year when I that was sitting in on
before we came up with our new way and
they accepted it they said you're right
we should have done it that way and they
changed and they did it our way so it's
never too late and this could cause
essential changes and improvement and
again a moral is don't stop at the
original problem so because we went on
for example composition so now my
overall conclusions so you see my two
case studies here's my overall
conclusions so first of all conclusions
for system builders so consult with your
tissues I mean it's good you love the
good things will happen in particular
explaining the problem is often gives
you a fresh viewpoint that makes you
understand it better so so I'm gonna
read you a quote from one of my academic
grandparents Albert Einstein I'm very
proud to say is one of my academic
grandparents tarski is the other one and
he said the following if I had an hour
to solve a problem and my life depended
on the answer I would spend the first 55
minutes figuring out the proper
questions to ask for if I knew the
proper questions I could solve the
problem list in five minutes
interesting so so the point is
understanding the problem deeply is step
one
really really really understand the
problem before you even begin working on
it
that's really an important thing to do
principled approaches can help help your
products if you're either well for
example you'll get better algorithms or
new algorithms maybe you'll be the first
one to have some algorithm or you'll
have the best algorithm if other people
have it too so it can help the product
by having better stuff in it
algorithm analysis can help you it can
it can provide for firmus expectations
you give you project guarantees
abstractions can expand the function of
your product like I mentioned about
using arbitrary arbitrary scoring
functions in fact the way they wrote it
in Clio they just called it F and you
know you could plug in F whatever you
want as long as this monotone and it
would work so using so it can expand the
function of the product for
theoreticians my conclusions are the
following that involvement with system
builders can help your theory that's my
basic message
first of all novel question to be asked
so some of these questions that I talked
about we're pretty even really being
asked this in a serious way the first I
think so so you'll get something new
you'll get instead of being you know the
27th iteration of some old problem that
everyone's been working on and even
making f son improvement you're suddenly
the one who's initiating and suddenly
everyone cares and everyone jumps on the
bandwagon cuz they're desperate for new
problems to work on and so yo you'll
really have an influence you'll get a
huge number of citations you know you
know you might win prizes it's you'll
good things will happen if you have
brand new problems with novel questions
new models new interesting areas of
study as I as I said implementation can
reveal weaknesses in the theory so for
example one piece of work we did it at
IBM was on
on backup different so back if there's a
backup manager called tivoli storage
manager the backs of people's data and
so I worked on that with McKee Italian
lorry stockmeyer and a great programmer
called Randall burns and we came up with
our algorithm where you backup things
you just send the diff you don't send
the whole thing the differ between the
old version the new version because
that's saved at the time bandwidth
that's really a huge issue and so that
really saved a lot on the band width and
but Randall experiment on real life data
and he came back to us and said you know
guys for very big day not very big files
doesn't work so well for the following
reason so we modified it to work well
for a big file so implementing to our
surprise you know it can give you things
that need to be improved your three will
be relevant I mean you really are
applying it to real world problems and
you will have practical impact that's my
talk thank you
instead of saying is the best possible
up to a constant factor
best possible to login factor or
something like that so that's one way
weakening it so at least it's something
and you've done some nice work on that
so that's one way of weakening but
you're right that's very hard it's hard
to find examples of this as optimality
because there's a brutally tough
condition to be optimal on every
instance so you're absolutely right many
problems just don't have it ought to
stop from algorithm so they're
non-trivial results you allow results
the press while going hey we gave an
approximate special modulus another
patented because people cared about it
that would give give the top K if you
were a little bit fuzzy about your if
you didn't care well I'm off by epsilon
I don't care so yes you can do that we
did that in fact in this case and then
they get early stopping that's cool
because you can actually as the thing is
running you can look at it and say I can
stop now
my answer is good enough you don't
really need to reach of all stress oh I
can do early stopping and that's
important for some people to do it early
stopping so and you get an approximate
answer with early stopping so absolutely
that's been studied we've studied that
now then you possibly look up to so you
don't get maybe the top k oh yeah this
is how you actually prove that it was
since this optimal the approximate that
no other approximately
you